you're watching Sky News in just a
moment the Press preview a first look at
what's on the front pages as they arrive
well let's um start by taking a look at
those front pages for you because in the
next half hour we'll see what's making
the headlines with the Guardians Deputy
political editor Jessica Elgort and the
political commentator Benedict Spence so
let us see what's on some of those front
pages for you now
the eye speaks to the former prime
minister sir Tony Blair who helped
broker The Good Friday agreement 25
years ago and says peace in Northern
Ireland shouldn't be taken for granted
the telegraph leads with the shooting
deaths of Two british-born Sisters in
the West Bank
the mirror hears that the king intends
to invite 850 people who've excelled in
community service to his coronation
that's the same story for the express
the mail carries excerpts from a new
book which claims the Princess of Wales
found it difficult to take part in
public walkabouts with Harry and Megan
after the Queen's death
according to the times 50 local housing
authorities have scrapped their home
building targets
the guardian understands that vaccines
tailored to the needs of specific cancer
patients could be ready in five years
time
and the start tells us that it's going
to be a very hot Easter
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by Jessica
elgot and Benedict
fence there they are welcome to you both
good to see you let's start with the
telegraph
and at their front page the two British
sisters are shot dead in the West Bank
that's on their their top story but
obviously since going to press we've had
the development of the tourists who was
killed in Tel Aviv this evening and that
attack when five other people possibly
six other people injured and in hospital
uh Benedict take us into to this story
because uh tonight's attack is a
culmination of several days of uh
attacks and counter-attacks and violence
yes uh this is a amid the backdrop of uh
tension uh escalating uh across Israel
at the moment and with the the along the
border with Lebanon of course the Jewish
holiday Passover coincides this year
with ramad and that's always likely to
sort of stir tensions there were clashes
uh out the temple Mountain at Al-Aqsa
mosque in Jerusalem between worshipers
and Israeli belis uh this shooting has
come in the Jordan Valley uh two girls
115 120
um and I think another family member
were in a car that was shot at
um and obviously this is just the latest
tragedy in you know it is a sort of a
never-ending series of tragedies across
um the region whenever you have these
sort of heightened tensions
um a lot of this is being sort of
sparked by the the clashes between the
the Israel Defense Forces and Hezbollah
the uh the Lebanese Army uh has said
that it is not entirely aware of any
military activities it's attempting to
put a stop to those sort of activities
but that hasn't stopped Israeli
retaliation against Targets in southern
Lebanon but also in Gaza as well because
of course there are the links there with
uh Hamas and I think it is a sign if
nothing else a of the the uh the the the
the aggressiveness if you like of the
Israeli authorities amid the backdrop of
protests against the Netanyahu
government and you know it's rhetoric
about needing to be stronger you know
some people have categorized it as the
most right-wing uh government in
Israel's history but at the same time of
the lack of ability in Lebanon of the
government to control what goes on there
uh Hezbollah is able to act almost
within punity it is able to launch
attacks
um against Israel if it wants to and so
you do have a very febrile situation
there um where you know when when you
have this sort of this Coalition of
religious tensions these this sort of
violence is often likely to spill over
as we have seen in Israel multiple times
in the past and with the two girls that
uh were shot uh Jessica we know that the
mother is uh seriously wounded as well
and the fear has to be that
this will further escalate as with the
attacking in Tel Aviv will further
escalate the already female situation
within Israel
yeah we've already had in as well I
think it's there it's one of the
deadliest starts
um you know to the year in Israel and in
the occupied West Bank um I think since
the second interfada so so which was in
in 2000s so
um that's meant that there's been about
90 Palestinians killed and roughly half
of them I think is estimated to have
been involved in in attacks um and then
um you know others who other kind of
Lone Wolf attacks from from Palestinians
have killed 16 Israelis or one of them
civilians as well as um you know those
of other nationalities who who've been
who've been killed in the last
um kind of 24 48 Hours
um that we've just been talking about
and
um and all of that comes and that all of
that is separate too but obviously there
is there are close links to the
political turmoil that's been going on
in the country since
um since the the election of an
incredibly right when government with
the very controversial figures in it and
taking part this this uh this this
judicial reform that Ben was talking
about
um the coalition's proposed overhaul of
uh of judges and and and and the and the
legal system which has seen Mass
protests of the country
um and has also you know involved quite
a lot of military reservists taking you
know being being part of uh of taking a
stand against some of those some of
those overhauls which then you know
obviously then has effects on on other
aspects of of Life there so um
and Netanyahu um the Israeli Prime
Minister publicly fired his defense
minister a couple of weeks ago although
he seems to be
still actually in post even though he
was even though he was um you know fired
and one of the things that set off most
of the protests so it does it all of
that feeds into what is obviously a very
volatile uh moment for the country yes
indeed and we'll keep across um further
developments there as I say
um five or six people who believe
injured and in hospital tonight in the
Tel Aviv attack let's move on to the
times and a housing story uh Benedict
about targets being scrapped her lead us
into this
yes uh the key figures that you need to
know about this story is the 55 local
authorities have now uh scrapped their
targets for building new houses as
everybody knows we have a housing
shortage already in this country so
that's good to hear and uh major
developers are now warning that the
latest shortfall could be exacerbated by
as much as 77 000. uh where you know it
just sort of makes you incredibly
optimistic for the future given the
house building uh is at the core of so
many of uh Britain's problems not just
house building actually development in
general you know there was a story the
other day uh doing the rounds about how
power showers might have to be uh banned
by the government because of a lack of
water which can be explained by the fact
that we don't build any reservoirs in
this country anymore and have them for
several decades well this is more to do
with housing targets
um and you know especially I think sort
of clustered around the South the
southeast of England London everybody is
acutely aware that there is a housing
shortage and that the short is
disproportionate dependent on region
there are some parts of the country that
have a surplus of housing but they just
don't have the people to fill them and
other places like London especially it
is impossible to buy a house for some
people whereas as little as 10 years ago
it was perfectly possible so that's uh
that's gonna I think do wonders for many
people who uh want to get on the housing
ladder the treasury know full well that
this is a serious obstacle to growth
especially if you have people trying to
get on the housing ladder you get um you
we had a net increase of half a million
people uh migrating to the country last
year you need houses for those people as
well if they're going to add to the
economy if you're not able to provide
these very basic things well then you've
got a bit of a crunch
um but as as has been described in the
times it is going to create what they
call a nimby's charter where people who
are opposed to uh development because
they think it's going to affect the
value of their house or it's going to
spoil their view or there's a family of
newts that are going to be imposed on
slightly you know that this is what
happens really is that there are
obstacles to house building at local
level local planning and very often
politicians simply aren't prepared to to
to to upset those people because they
know that it potentially means their
jobs their roles uh their election in
the future so a difficult situation
where we have a conservative government
that knows the world that we need growth
desperately uh but also knows that its
voters are diametrically opposed to
building any new houses so a wonderful
impasse that we're here to have and this
story in the time suggests that it's
only going to get worse we note your
sarcasm uh there in your commentary Ben
is it Jessica I mean it's quite quite a
lot substantial isn't it 55 local
authorities suspending their development
plans and developers are warning that 77
000 fewer homes could be built each year
with the fewest homes being built in the
areas with the greatest housing demand
what is going to happen
yeah it's extraordinary isn't it it's
actually and I think that that number of
houses that are pausing these local the
number of councils that are pausing
these local housing plans has gone up
because we we did we did quite a similar
story in the guardian in January and
then it was about 30 so there's clearly
you know it's clearly rising and and and
local authorities
um kind of taking note of what other
neighboring places are doing because
they feel they can't fulfill these plans
and I think it's worth going back to you
know how we've gone ourselves into this
extraordinary situation that there was
this
um sort of big Rebellion
um on the leveling up Bill which uh was
just after receiving that became prime
minister
um about 50
um MPS planning to Rebel this was when
when the Tories were really in the kind
of depths of the pot of the of the
postless trust polling
um and lots of MPS were kind of
resorting to taking very sort of popular
local stances
um in various areas including you know
including some fairly safe tour receipts
but you know in plenty not especially in
the south of England where there's the
biggest housing pressures
um and Rishi sunak just didn't have the
political Capital to resist
um this
um you know so early on and in the
circumstances to resist this this
amendment and so it was just accepted
that we would that we would scale back
no no longer pursue any kind of
mandatory
um housing targets and and that that has
you know it's such a it really shows how
kind of these these things we talk about
as like in the Westminster bubble and
and you know knock-on effects about
Rishi notes Authority and what
individual MPS are motivated to do on
amendments you know it can have these
enormous knock-on effects um on on
housing ability of young people to buy a
home and and on on growth in the country
Benedict we've just got a minute for a
good news story a truly good news story
um in the guardian uh yeah Jessica's
paper personalized cancer jobs may be
ready in five years time tailored
vaccines for cancer patients
yes this is the chief medical officer of
moderna who has said that we have we've
made significant progress in in the last
12 months to to two years and he does
say quite straightforwardly that it is
as a result of covid and the money and
time and effort that went into research
and covered jobs to make them
effectively in a short period of time
this is expedited the process that could
have taken decades uh made it much
shorter and you know we only have a
short amount of time so I don't think
there's much more for me to say if this
is true it's a fantastic step forward
um in medical science and it's going to
benefit so many millions of people if we
are able to get this out at scale within
five years yes it would be amazing
Benedict and Jessica at the moment thank
you we are going to take a break coming
up plans for the coronation continue to
take shape we'll talk about some of the
community service Champions who secured
an invitation when we come back
[Music]
thank you
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview still with me Jessica algot and
Benedict spent there they are
finally made of your appearance um let's
start with the mirror in this section
and looking to the coronation on May the
6th the king is going to do things a
little differently how so Jessica
yeah what we've heard is that the
speculation that the king is planning
this slimmed down event but actually
what it seems to have done is really
expanded to to to to people who have
been contributing to communities through
kind of charity work or public service
um young people involved in the prince's
trust and Charities like bernardo's
they're all people are being invited to
kind of watch the the corridation
um including in the Abbey grounds
um uh and lots of those kind of really
famous organizations like the you know
the scouts Girl Guides
um some of the some of the examples are
really kind of heartwarming about who
will be invited to to take part you know
a kind of real spectrum of Britain you
know some uh including cancer survivors
a police officer who wrote the Atlantic
um a couple who turned their their bike
shop into an emergency delivery story
service during the pandemic
um 800 50 local Champions so it's it's a
good way to kind of expand it and make
the rest of the country feel really part
of it rather than just have kind of
Lords and Ladies and and visiting
overseas dignitaries there and Benedict
pictured on the front of the mirror is
13 year old Max Lucy who uh camped in
his back Garden for three years to raise
funds for a local hospice I mean it
really is uh making the coronation a
celebration for everyone and uh you know
everybody that's
interested or not in fact
yes and I mean good for good for young
Max who may or may or may not be another
victim of the housing crisis I'm not
sure but he's certainly he's put it to
good use at the very least in raising
money for the hospice I quite like this
to be honest I I I like that he's doing
things a little bit differently that he
wants to be a slightly more yeah I I
don't want to use the sort of you know
the word modern King but he wants to
sort of reinvent the the rules slightly
why don't you want to use the word
modern
well because he's not really modern
that's the problem let's try as he might
you know King Charles is not a modern
man at all he's modernizing the monarchy
if you like by going back in time I mean
he had the the image of the Green Man on
his invitations to the coronation which
you know I don't know how much how far
back into British mythology we need to
go to get to that but that was quite
amusing but I like that he does things
his own way I like that he doesn't
necessarily stick to protocol or
tradition and you know it is nice that
Ordinary People are recognized for
something other than simply the New
Year's honors list or or things like
that that actually that they all sorts
of Ordinary People perhaps even some
quite hot people who aren't Bishops or
Lords will be invited to this special
event and I just I quite like that he's
doing his thing okay staying with the
Royals we read in the mail that uh Kate
found Walkabout with Harry and Megan one
of the hardest things she's ever had to
do Jessica
yeah I mean it's possibly a strange way
to describe a short walk but um but
obviously not to not on the play that
there there clearly is a lot of tensions
between the two brothers uh and and that
and that was before you know we saw that
the the all the revelations in in Prince
Harry's book that the you know the
clearly the two are not on speaking
terms
um and that there was very difficult you
know there's very bad blood between her
um and Megan herself so
um all of this of course coming before
you know a month before the coronation
where we still aren't actually sure
whether whether um Harry and Megan will
will make it to the the coronation at
all
um especially because of of all of those
Revelations that came out at the back
end of last year so
um but yes this is another book uh you
know which seems to kind of try and
potentially uh put Caster as more
negative like the departure of of Harry
and Megan from from the family
um and and sort of putting some
background around the demands and
suspect they found the authors fan
people slightly more willing to brief
about all of that since uh since Harry's
book came out yeah I mean do you see it
as a direct response to spare Benedict
I have potentially I was walking through
bunlo in in the Czech Republic the other
day and I walked past a Bookshop and
there were copies of Prince Harry's
books in the window then I thought I
can't get away from this story there
will always be books being written about
this thing it's never ending
um I do think that it's it's important
the perhaps who Waits until you know the
the entirety of the passage is revealed
um yeah Catherine might have been
referring to the fact that it that there
is bad blood between the brothers but
equally it could have been uh the fact
that you know the queen had just died
and emotionally it must have been very
difficult for her to have to put on a
brave face and go out to meet the public
like that but you know this is this is a
book that uh the male tells us has
Snippets about Harry losing his temper
with King Charles uh about him ranting
on the phone to the queen about how
difficult life was and that she found it
very difficult so it is it does seem to
be a rebuttal to that you know one side
of the story that we have had and if
you're interested in that sort of thing
I'm sure there will be no end of these
stories that will continue to drip out
uh for the years to come yeah suggesting
that you're not interested by your tone
there Benedict um and Jessica both thank
you we'll see you in the next hour